es war halo alle miteinander mein name
ist luca und herzlich willkommen wir
heute zu einem neuen video auf einem
kanal ihr seht her ich habe auch ich hab
ich habe heute auf jeden fall bereits im
titel eingeblendet es geht heute um
michael pablo ich wollte da eigentlich
gar nicht zu machen weil ich weiß dass
ich selber der vergangenheit nicht der
typ war mit einer weißen weste was
skandale und dummheiten angeht
allerdings ist dass das ist champions
league erst mal ganz kurz falls ihr das
ganze thema überhaupt nicht mitbekommen
habt amiga pablo hat vor einem monat
dieses video hochgeladen meinen outing
sandra vom 31 3 watt strom
auf jeden fall habe ich mir das video
auch angeschaut und da geht's halt
einfach da ich erachte kommt wir schauen
einfach mal kurz rein
heute habe ich ein sehr sehr ernstes
thema durch zu besprechen und ich weiß
es wird sehr sehr viele von uns
schockieren dass das war erstmal die
erste sache wo ich mir gedacht habe
wieso schockieren wir leben in 2020 wir
sind tolerant wie eh und je und warum
also ich finde homosexualität allgemein
ist einfach gang und gäbe ich weiß doch
früher als thomas hitzlsberger sich
geoutet hat dass das habe ich immer noch
in meinem kopf drin dass bei wochenlang
haben die medien das tod geschlachtet
das thema das war so ein großes ding und
mittlerweile es ist einfach völlig
normal ich verstehe nicht warum leute
allgemein das so groß machen müssen und
vor allem dann die mit pablo der nach
seinem outing video hat noch 30 weitere
videos über das gleiche thema gemacht
hat aber ja wir schauen aber kurz weiter
in sein outing videos hat auch mega
angst davor das video hier zu machen
weil ich meine community kenne und ich
habe ein bisschen angst dass sich hate
für dieses video kriege das war auch so
eine sache die fand ich irgendwie ein
bisschen komisch er beleidigt da wird ja
indirekt seine eigenen zuschauer also
seine eigene community und stellt sie
als intolerant da
was dann ist mehr als bewusst geworden
ich stehe auf jungs
und das ist quasi ja die kernaussage des
videos er zeigt dann hier noch mal eine
person mit der er dann zusammen ist ich
weiß gar nicht genau wie er heißt sascha
ich habe das video gesehen und hab dann
auch gesehen die sehr viele youtuber
darauf reagiert hat und ich dachte
einfach nur so ich musste jetzt nicht
darauf reagieren so ich klar ich feiere
jetzt sein content nicht aber wenn er
schwul ist okay dann soll er schwul sein
dass es 2020 leb dein leben glückwunsch
euch beiden doch in den tagen und wochen
nach seinem outing hat miguel pablo das
thema immer und immer und immer weiter
behandelt auf seinem kanal und ich
dachte mir irgendwie erst auf zu beginn
ja ist ja cool dass er darüber aufklärt
sowie lief dazwischen uns wie carmen
dass ihr habe ich das gemerkt aber dann
kam halt solche videos beispielsweise
oder solche videos oder solche videos
oder solche videos wo ich mir dann
einfach nur noch dachte ist jetzt auch
mal gut das wird so als wäre das alles
irgendwie promo da habe ich das ganze
auch ein bisschen hinterfragt und dann
vor einigen tagen hat der liebe kuchen
tv ein video gelegt was ich euch jetzt
einfach mal einblenden werde
[Musik]
auf dem video konntet ihr gerade
unschwer erkennen dass da miguel pablo
auf einer party war und etwas mit einem
mädchen hatte und als ich dieses lied
video dann gesehen habe dachte ich mir
im ersten moment hey ich hab immer noch
an miguel pablo geglaubt und obwohl ja
viele andere youtuber infrage gestellt
haben ob er wirklich schwul ist oder ob
er sich das alles irgendwie ausgedacht
hat habe ich trotzdem mir hey vielleicht
dass er bisexuell steht auch frauen und
männer vielleicht ist sie gerade einfach
in der phase wo er sich da noch finden
muss was seine sexuelle orientierung
angeht war ich gespannt auf die
reaktionen die von miguel kabel auf das
video von kuchen tv kommt weil zu dem
zeitpunkt hat dann auch noch herr
newstime darüber berichtet und noch zwei
drei andere große youtuber haben das
gesehen und dann dann kam so das
eigentor des jahrhunderts mein outing
war fake
das video ist 5 sekunden er blendet zu
beginnen jetzt gerade hier eine szene
ein wo er seinen angeblichen freund
sascha auf den mund küsst und sagt
direkt danach scheiße
miguel ich checks nicht man hat früher
schon in einigen videos rausholen können
dass er eventuell schwulenfeindlich sein
könnte weil er das wort schwul und vor
allem [ __ ] sehr häufig als
beleidigung genutzt hat aber wir schauen
erst mal weiter einige werden jetzt so
anbau ich hatte recht
bitte gib mir eine chance also vor
eineinhalb monaten habe ich mich geoutet
das video hat fast jeder gesehen ist das
1,4 millionen klicks es war platz
einzelnen trends
ich frag mich einfach warum muss er das
jetzt erwähne so hey ich habe mich vor
einem monat geoutet das war scheiße aber
es hat viele klicks und deshalb wieder
gesehen und zwar an den trends werden
sich jetzt wie es ist sacha und ich wir
haben aufnahmen gemacht bevor wir das
gekostet haben
ob man da noch glauben kann wollen
einfach nur klarstellen dass es nichts
schlimmes wimmer schwules
ist ein guter ansatz ich verstehe den
punkt und ich fühl den punkt miguel die
sache ist nur du hast es halt komplett
verkackt der hintergedanke ist und gut
aber die ausführung ist extrem schlecht
ich habe mehr zu sagen gesagt keiner
wird das selten alle werden sagen weil
ich dachte deutschlands mega toleranz
erinnert ihr euch an das video was wir
uns gerade davor geschaut haben sein
outing in dem er gesagt hat ich habe
auch mega angst davor das video hier zu
machen weil ich meine community kenne
und ich habe ein bisschen angst dass
sich hält für dieses video kriege und
jetzt sagt er ich habe mehr als zu sagen
gesagt keiner wird das selten die logik
irgendwo gesehen
leider viel zu viele die gesagt haben
war schwul ich gucke ich mich mehr uns
lohnt
sorry dass ich die ganze zeit
unterbreche ich habe mich ein bisschen
vorbereitet auf die reaction hier heute
wie bereits gesagt das ist ein guter
hintergedanken der meint er wollte das
experiment nach einigen tagen beenden
allerdings hat er auch noch einigen
tagen dieses video hochgeladen und zwar
genau genommen fünf videos nach seinem
outing kam unsere die ems nach dem
outing spätestens da und ich meine
wirklich alle allerspätestens weil nach
seinem outing hat auch videos gemacht
wie eine touch my body challenge plus
boyfriend oder haben wir schon
miteinander punkt um punkt
nach dem video wo sie auf die msn gehen
diese bekommen haben wo unter anderem
dann auch beleidigungen dabei waren wäre
es doch der perfekte zeitpunkt gewesen
das experiment zu beenden weil dann
hättet ihr 23 videos dazu gemacht es
glaubhaft dargestellt und den leuten
dann in dem video gezeigt hey einige
haben uns wirklich beleidigt aber da
wollen wir euch jetzt sagen das war ein
experiment es ist komplett normal
homosexuell zu sein aber miguel ja der
hat ein bisschen weiter ausgeschlachtet
dass wir wollten das experiment
durchziehen und am ende hätten wir sogar
gutes resultat gehabt in den leuten
gezeigt es soll schon gar nicht so
tolerant ist
gutes resultat
wenn ich den leuten zeigen dass
deutschland nicht tolerant ist
aber also super der resultat lügen haben
kurze beine weit kommt im ans licht und
ich mach das jetzt nicht weil punkte vor
dieses video gemacht hat war so dass
auch er sagt die wahrheit kommt immer
ans licht lügen haben kurze beine und
ich mach das jetzt nicht weil kuchen tv
das video gelegt hat das ist auch wieder
ein widerspruch in enns fünf bis zehn
sekunden der einen seite sagt hey die
wahrheit kommt immer alles licht und
irgendwann habe safe verpackt und dann
kam die wahrheit ans licht mit diesem
lied video auf der party war mit einem
mädchen was hat und dann sagt er hey ich
muss aber nicht wegen dem video gemacht
warum hast du es dann gemacht mein
konnte ich brauche geld gebraucht
klickst du auf eine wand zum geld
verdienen um das boot nach hause zu
bringen
scheiß auf soziales experiment ja wir
wollen zeigen wie intolerant deutschland
ist schade darauf gestoßen wie gameboys
sein boot nach hause bringen ich hatte
gar kein geld mehr ich habe nicht mal
100 euro monat von ihm gar nichts mehr
dazu wurden all meinen videos und
monetarisiert wegen copyright claims
seine videos wurden en monetarisiert
wegen copyright claims doch auch nach
diesem video namens mein auto war fake
von vor drei tagen habe ich mir gedacht
hey dazu hat umgehen video gemacht dazu
hat die monte ein video gemacht dazu hat
haben verschiedene leute die wirklich
homosexuell sind idiot gemacht und alle
haben ihre meinung sagt und alle haben
die gleiche meinung die ich und ich
glaube auch wie ihr alle da draußen das
geht einfach nicht ich habe mir trotzdem
gedacht hey ich möchte da nicht zu sagen
die leute haben schon genug dazu gesagt
doch dann kam jetzt was was mich noch
mehr aufgeregt hat wo ich einfach dachte
dicker das kannst du doch jetzt nicht
auch noch bringen fähig outing mein
vater reagiert
er instrumentalisiert jetzt sein vater
ich mir also ihr merkt es glaube ich an
vielen stellen mir fehlen einfach
wirklich die worte
ich fand es einfach krass dass miguel
dann seinen vater instrumentalisiert hat
und mit ihm noch mal ein video zu dem
verkauf gedreht hat und dann vor allem
im titel geschrieben hat mein vater
reagiert ja und dann sagt er auch noch
so sachen wie hass like da wenn ihnen
die komplette doku sehen wollt über das
soziale dinge und erachtet es immer
weiter aus ich habe mir einfach gedacht
kommt er hat jetzt ein statement
hochgeladen das war fake und jetzt kommt
erstmal gar nichts weil er hat sich
30 eigentore gerade geschossen aber dann
die habe ich mir auch gedacht dass alles
gut sein lokale leute machen da war zu
alles easy aber dann dann dass das fand
ich wahnsinn wir haben verkackt
man denkt jetzt vielleicht hey da
auch neue statement von wegen meinen
statement video war scheiße das habe ich
mir im ersten moment gedacht und ich
glaube das haben sich auch viele von
euch gedacht dann habe ich das video
angeklickt also erst mal für euch für
den zeitlichen überblick von drei tagen
kamen das in die auflösung dass das
outing fake war vor zwei tagen kam dann
direkt danach 24 schon später fake
outing mein vater reagiert und dann
wieder einen tag später kam jetzt das
video und ich dachte mir hey er redet
dann nochmal drüber stellt noch mal ein
bisschen was klar
aber nein
seht einfach selbst das video beginnt
ich fühle mich willkommen zu diesem
neuen video auf einem kanal
ich bin froh ich bin auf diese gefahr
wird ich bin heute auch dabei hat er wie
du denn die sind jetzt media markt und
ich wollte ich unbedingt hin darauf
wegen diesem teils lang schwarze
cargohose und wessis
ich rutsche fast schon aus so viel ich
habe
es geht 0,0
um sein statement
er nutzt hier seinen eigenen ruin
noch klick bailly aus um noch mehr views
zu machen
alle leute klicken auf das video denken
sich hey das ist irgendwie ein statement
zum statement aber nein
die kaufen sich da irgendwelche
haarbürsten im media markt gibt an mit
seinem privat friseur
das kann man nicht in worte fassen er
hat verkackt
er macht ein statement
dennoch mehr verkackt dann zieht er sein
vater mit rein hat dadurch noch mehr
verpackt
und jetzt macht er einfach weiter als
wäre nichts gewesen wäre aber nicht
einfach mit dem fussball challenge ein
schwarz-weißes am nil wir haben verkackt
eine panne jagt die nächste viel spaß
bei der einzig wahren banjo ich hoffe
einfach nur noch mal hier jetzt mal
direkt bezogen auf die ich michael pablo
dass du wirklich jetzt mal daraus
gelernt hast und ich sage so was total
und ich habe das auch noch nie gesagt
aber vielleicht würde ich an einer
stelle wirklich den youtube-kanal
löschen und in anderen berufsweg
einschlagen weil das ist
es ist krass wir sehen uns morgen wieder
in einem neuen video in alter frische
[Musik]